so because my video on adamantium and
vibranium was so well-received what I
want to do here is expand this
discussion to the realm of our series of
comic book concepts and take a second to
focus on guru metal the material used to
forge Thor's hammer so if you recall my
previous videos on Asgard we talked
about how that realm was best compared
to a house if the home you lived in
where the entirety of the mobile
universe the closet in your bedroom
would be an analogy for Asgard now
within this closet exists a completely
self-contained universe with its own
dimensions taking the form of the nine
realms each of which how does his own
distinct appearances races and creatures
with one of these realms being called
nidavellir originally appearing in issue
number 103 of journey into mystery the
publications serving as the source of
four stories leading into the launch of
his own title madaba Lear was originally
depicted with a force and mountainous
appearance not unlike earth but home to
dwarves who lived underground having
said that because the information during
this time was a little scant and that
model wanted to keep facets of Thor's
origin mysterious for the purpose of
maintaining intrigue while also allowing
for usable content in the future almost
nothing was known about the origin of
Thor's hammer or room metal with the
exception of the fact that Mjolnir had
been forged by the dwarves and contained
the enchantment of Odin only allowing it
to be wielded by those who were deemed
worthy in addition to this since Thor's
hammer was the only source of room metal
known within Marvel Comics our only
understanding of his properties came in
for his use throughout his various
publications that said in 2004 as part
of the lead up to civil war because for
was such a powerful figure in Marvel
Comics and could have easily swayed
victory for the side of Iron Man or
Captain America in addition to the
Avengers disassembled event laying the
foundation for civil war though our
experienced his own disassembled event
in the form of Thor Ragnarok
now if you're interested in learning
more about that storyline I have a link
in the description to a video on it but
in the opening segment of the story with
issue number eighty writers Michael
oming and Daniel Berman provided a
definitive origin of the hammer and it's
forgery in uber metal what we're told is
that in the early days of asgaard prior
to the birth of four and following
Odin's initial rise to power
Odin had instructed the dwarves to forge
a weapon capable of striking down the
strongest of Asgard's enemies regardless
of the location or power because asgaard
had not yet become as intertwined in the
goings-on of earth as it had following
the introduction of for Asgard itself
remained self-contained using its
various resources to form the weapons
and armor necessary to maintain his
position and the pantheon of the nine
realms in addition to this since the DA
volleyer was home to the dwarves and
housed a multitude of jewels and metal
guru existed as one of a multitude of
materials available for crafting now
where rube I'd solve is one of these
strongest metals in the universe its
properties actually become more enhanced
whenever they're enchanted using magic
now how exactly it is that magical
enchantment improves the hammer is not
explicitly known but the generally
accepted idea is that it somehow draws
the molecules of uber metal closer
together making them more durable and
heavier allowing leaven to inflict more
damage this I a note here is that
because it was only been used a handful
of times including Yule near beta ray
Bill's hammer Stormbreaker and Odin
staff as well as Tony Stark Thor buster
honor these uses indicate that guru is
strictly used as a material for weaponry
with no known applications going towards
construction designs meaning there are
no metal guru buildings or wires
having said that while we do not have a
way to measure our metals tensile
strength and ability to hold objects
Marvel has provided various instances of
the metals weaknesses and
ineffectiveness against other metals
giving us as the reader an idea of where
uber resides and a larger model
landscape in terms of its materials
referencing my video on vibranium and
adamantium while truer metal is
extremely durable and capable of
dismantling almost all other metals in
existence regarding vibranium
like any metal who resides on the force
of impact to inflict damage on objects
to sidetrack for a second within the
realm of physics impact forces used to
describe the result of what happens when
two objects collide with one another at
high velocities and the resulting
interaction when an impact occurs the
friction between the colliding object
creates extreme heat while the shear
force of impact creates sound because
the major of wakandan vibranium allows
it to absorb all forms of energy
including heat and sound
uber metal has no effect at the point of
impact and aside from the effects of
vibranium absorbing those energies
nothing would actually happen now for
those we who might be looking to the
scene from Avengers when Thor's hammer
hit Captain America's shield this was
actually an incorrect depiction if the
movie had followed the premise of the
comics you would have heard nothing from
the impact and there would have been no
shockwave of any kind
however with adamantium things are a
little bit different where were metal
itself is below adamantium in terms of
durability the hammer of Thor is
actually stronger than adamantium
covered in 2009 s Wolverine vs. Thor a
three-part story by French Harry and
release as a digital comic where the
main story saw the two being tricked
into fighting one another by Loki during
the battle Wolverine had attempted to
slice the hammer for using his
adamantium claws but inflicted no damage
whatsoever now where this story does
take place outside of the main mobile
continuity as far as I am aware this is
the only instance in Marvel Comics when
Wolverine was shown incapable of
damaging forest hammer at the same time
this is also due to a bit of cheating
and that because Thor's hammer is
magically infused its normal properties
of uber metal were bolstered allowing it
to withstand the potential damage of
Wolverine without actually taking any
damage itself now with the idea of
enchantments in mind this is really
where uber metal stands out
unlike vibranium adamantium carbonadium
or almost any other metal guru has a
natural affinity for magic meaning that
assuming they could wield it beams like
dr. strange or Scarlet Witch could
actually channel their abilities into
the hammer for enhance its durability or
bestow it with a multitude of different
effects and then use them to their
advantage
conversely uber metal allows existing
enchantments to be passed to its user
creating a kind of increased durability
and strength now where there is no
instance that I am aware of where anyone
but a handful of people have been to
essentially able to lift doors hammer
let alone enhance its magical properties
this video supports the nature of guru
in that like all other metals in Marvel
Comics it has its own properties making
it unique in and of itself however its
affinity with magic does not mean the
metal is capable of overcoming the magic
of others whether there have been
multiple instances of this the most
popular example came in the form of the
Mighty Thor issue number 429 from 1991
written by Tom DeFalco with a story
sought for doing battle against
juggernaut during the conflict Thor had
thrown his hammer at que Marco which
resulted in methane happening now the
significance behind this is that with
Java not being empowered by the demon
magic of CID Iraq and m2t residing
within his own dimension called the
crimson cosmos as long as he possesses
the crimson gem and can utilize his
power in his jabber not form que Marco
is essentially unstoppable and immortal
now where this isn't designed to be a
comparison between Asgardians and Sid
Iraq it is designed to tell us that the
magical abilities of uber metal in the
form of Thor's hammer has its limits and
it's not infinitely powerful instead
like any magical object within the world
of comics uber metal in all of its forms
ranging from Thor's hammer to Heimdall
sword and everything in between is
merely a tool and is contingent on how
it's used by its wielder and the various
abilities they're able to command with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end hope you guys
enjoyed it and now we'll catch you guys
on it peace